with june 1st approaching when we move
to 100
capacity businesses are looking to hire
and the jobs need to be filled right
away
however it hasn't been easy many many
employers are doing whatever they can in
hopes to
apply from incentives to bonuses to
higher hourly rates madison kimbrough
joining us now live from casa don juan
in the arts district madison
this particular restaurant increased
wages in hopes of quick hires right
yes they did and they really know how
competitive the market is right now
just take a look at their door right
here it says now hiring for
all positions and while business is
steady they along with several other
restaurants around town are offering
wages
up to 20 dollars an hour just to keep up
thanks to the loyal customers that we
have they keep coming back
it's full steam ahead as we approach
returning to full capacity
as customers return business owners are
trying to keep up with the demand
especially when it comes to dining
manager jesus salas at casa don juan
is offering as much as eighteen dollars
an hour with the baseline being eleven
dollars an hour
for those just starting it's been a
struggle trying to get uh
new employees we lost a few due to the
pandemic we have raised our pay rate
due to the competition that
we have right now and they're not alone
skinny fats
offering 20 dollars an hour they're
looking for line cooks dishwashers and
servers
hot and juicy crawfish also making sure
employees make the same
i think it's great for for the economy
it's good for
you know the people that are getting the
job you know it's a competition
salas says it's all about offering
employees the whole package
and that's why at casa don juan they're
offering benefits too
health insurance we provide that for our
employees
and it's uh the company's paying you
know is free for them
so that's you know that is the plus
so like i mentioned if you are looking
for work all of these places are
hiring at competitive wages and we
posted a bunch of businesses hiring
on our website now if you are an
employer looking for workers
go ahead and let us know you can email
us and let us know if you are looking
for employees for your staff and we'll
put you right on the list
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now